les premiers travaux ont pris finalement
cinq mois de retard le tram très express
commencent à voir le jour plus de dix
ans après le lancement du projet les
travaux dits préparatoires comme la
découpe des arbres ont débuté en février
notamment sur le terminus à
saint-cyr-l'ecole nos engagements là en
ce moment
des travaux de sondage pour savoir
qu'est ce qui se trouve à l'intérieur de
ce terrain puisque nous allons dès
suspicion de présence de munitions et
donc une fois que ces travaux ces
sondages auront été réalisés nous
commencerons les travaux de terrassement
qui auront lieu jusqu'à l'été ses
premiers travaux devraient durer un an
avant le lancement de la phase
structurel avec l'installation des rails
sur cette partie du terrain et de la
station terminus derrière sept buts dans
sa première partie le tram très express
poursuit le prolongement de la grande
ceinture ouest au nord jusqu'à saint
germain en laye et au sud jusqu'à saint
cyr l'école sont un tracé de 19 km et la
création de six nouvelles gares c'est
vraiment un projet qui permet de mailler
le réseau de permettre des déplacements
à l'intérieur du des plats de du
département et donc de faciliter la vie
des yvelinois dans leur département
leurs déplacements quotidiens
la mise en service du tram très express
est prévu après 2020 à terme plus de
vingt mille voyageurs par jour devrait
emprunter cette nouvelle ligne